alrighty folks this is the ben shapiro
show you may have noticed that we are
not opening as we normally do and that's
because today is a crucial day for our
company and i think frankly a crucial
day for the country we as a company are
doing the most important thing that we
have ever done we do need your help
today the obama administration finally
put out their long-awaited osha rule
from the occupational safety and health
administration they are promulgating a
rule be an administrative agency that
forces every company with over 100
employees to force their employees to
either vaccinate
or test
or be fired
this is the mandate it is coming from
the bind administration i'm gonna go
through all the details in one moment
and just be aware this is the emergency
temporary standard they are already
preparing a permanent standard that will
extend
to every company not companies with over
100 employees every company they are
saying this openly they are preparing a
standard that could apply not only to
every company but could force fully
vaccinated people to be massed
could get rid of any exceptions for
prior immunity there are no exceptions
for prior immunity in this osha rule as
it stands if you already had coveted you
had it three weeks ago if you're not
vaccinated you still have to vax test
every week or be fired under this
particular mandate from osha
if made permanent they would consider
getting rid of testing as an alternative
to vaccination so you wouldn't even be
able to test it out of it or maybe
making tests daily or daily
and making sure that you use higher
standards of masks and maybe even at
your workplace you'd have to have social
distancing there's no end date for this
the binding administration has no end
date for this regulation
it's supposed to fully kick into place
as of early january to supposedly allow
time for employers to force their
employees to get fast they're going to
force millions of people out of work
they're going to force millions of
people to choose between quitting their
jobs
and getting vaccinated
in a time when the pandemic is already
ending and everybody who wants of acts
has been able to get a vax and now even
children can get a vacs this is
authoritarian it is garbage it is
anti-scientific we need your help and we
have already spent tens of thousands of
dollars on our lawyers we filed a
lawsuit as of this morning and we are
taking them to court we'll fight this
all the way to the supreme court if need
be
obviously lawsuits cost a lot of money
and you have to have great legal
partnership in order to win and that's
why we are working with the folks over
at alliance defending freedom and over
at the dillon law group we need your
help to make that happen obviously
because lawsuits cost tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands sometimes millions
of dollars and this one will probably
end up at the supreme court we're going
to fight it tooth and nail on behalf of
our employees this is how you fight
you got to fight them in court you got
to fight them with every resource at
your disposal individual action here is
great but what really matters more what
really matters more is your employers
standing up for you what really matters
more
is your state and local government
standing up for you so we need your help
because again this stuff is expensive
and we are taking a risk here right we
are not going to comply with these
mandates
and the risk of not complying with the
mandates is tens of thousands of dollars
for each violation
if biden got his way he would bankrupt
hundreds of companies including
companies like ours that is the goal and
we're gonna fight this all the way so we
need your help
please subscribe we really do need your
help over it's
dailywire.com subscribe you can use the
code do not comply get 25 off you get
all of our great content but really more
importantly this is the time
where we need to get together and fight
this thing how's osha going to enforce
this apparently osha is going to send
out agents i kid you not to workplaces
to check in on you and
for willful violations not stan standard
violations are like you make a mistake
because you oh you just oops you didn't
do the osha rule so you get a 14 000
fine for willful violations right we are
saying we don't want to comply for
willful violations a single violation
can amount to up to 140
they are seeking to bankrupt anyone who
is in favor of liberty here this is
authoritarian not just because of the
content of it but because of the form of
it they're using an administrative
agency that is acting outside the scope
of its authority to force every major
employer and mid-size employer in the
united states to force vaccines on their
employees
and their permanent standard is much
more onerous than that and it'll extend
to everybody
they're openly saying this okay they're
not hiding the ball they put forward a
490 page regulation today
i've gone through it
it is more restrictive and more vicious
than we thought it was going to be our
lawyers are already fighting it as of
right now
okay on a procedural level
it's insane to think that osha which was
not designed to do this is going to be
issuing vast regulations across the
entire scope of american life without
regard for state and local rights
without regai without regard to the
rights of private property owners and
private business owners or employees
we're the real targets of this right
it's not the employers who are the
targets it's the employees who are the
targets this is the federal government
trying to make employers their policemen
in their vaccination efforts and listen
i'm vaccinated my wife is vaccinated my
parents are vaccinated you know because
you listen to the show i'm a huge fan of
the vaccines this isn't about that this
is about the authoritarian mandate that
is now being leveraged on the american
people it's disgusting it's vile we're
gonna fight it every single step of the
way again we need your help please go
subscribe right now dailywire.com
subscribe code do not comply for 25
percent off so another note here today
is the day you need to call your
republican representative particularly a
republican senator
and your democratic senator and you need
a congressional review act vote today on
this osha regulation
it will be officially promulgated
tomorrow there is something called the
congressional review act the
congressional review act allows the
senate of the united states to reject an
agency interpretation of an authorizing
statute
the democrats have control of the senate
republicans need to force them today
to have a vote
on whether or not they are in favor of
this perverse and tyrannical regulation
if democrats all vote in favor fine they
get to own it but they need to be made
to own it so call your senator today and
tell them they need to vote
on a congressional review act
review of this regulation
they need to push the democrats to do it
again if the democrats won't do it then
it's on them and they get to own the
tyranny okay so what exactly is in this
new osha regulation which will affect
you
in all likelihood because the vast
majority of employees in the united
states work for businesses that have
over 100 employees
so according to the osha
vaccination and testing ets fact sheet
the ets is necessary to protect
unvaccinated workers from the risk of
contracting covet 19 at work okay here
is the problem with this right off the
bat you know what is supposed to protect
unvaccinated workers
from the risk of contracting copper19 at
work
them
you've had that you've had every ability
for months and months and months and
months go get the backs if you don't
want the facts
that's your problem we live in a free
country the ets is essentially saying
that we are going to protect you from
yourself because you're too stupid to
make decisions
this un-american bull
the rule covers all employers with a
total of 100 or more employees with a
few exceptions described low by the way
they're not cramming this down on all
the public employees or by the way if
they wanted to do this on a federal
governmental level you know what they
could do they could cram this down
on everybody who receives federal
benefits you've noticed they're not
doing that they're not attaching your
vaccination status to your food stamps
interesting
covered employers must develop implement
and enforce a mandatory covet-19
vaccination policy with an exception for
employers that instead adopt a policy
requiring employees to either elect to
get vaccinated or to undergo regular
covet 19 testing and wear a face
covering at work
this fact should highlight some of the
additional requirements of the ets
employers should consult the standard
for full details
so who's covered private employers with
100 or more employees firm or corporate
wide
in states with osha approved state plans
state and local government employers as
well as private employers with 100 or
more employees will be covered by state
occupational safety and health
requirements
interesting
interesting the distinction between
private and public right there weird
maybe it maybe has to do with public
unions
which workplaces are not covered
workplaces covered under the safer
federal workforce tax task force covered
19 workplace safety settings where any
employee provides healthcare services or
healthcare support services because
they're already covered by the
healthcare etfs
workplaces of employers who have fewer
than 100 employees in total which of
course makes no sense making the
exception is specifically designed to
exempt the most sympathetic businesses
but it has nothing to do with science
has nothing to do with logic if you have
a small mom and pop shop with four
employees in a small hole in the wall
just as good a chance you're gonna get
covered there as if you're working at a
big open-air office like we have
in nashville with a couple hundred
employees
also public employers in states without
state plans
are not covered by the ets interesting
if an employer is covered by the ets
does that mean all of its employees must
follow the provisions no the
requirements of the ets do not apply to
employees who do not report to a
workplace where other individuals are
present employees while working from
home or employees who work exclusively
outdoors so basically if you work in an
office you're screwed
or
your employer has to make you work from
home
or you got to work in a park somewhere
what does the ets require employers to
do
develop implement and enforce a
mandatory covenant vaccination policy
with an exception for employers that
instead establish implement and enforce
a policy allowing employees to elect
either to get vaccinated or to undergo
weekly covenant 19 testing and wear a
face covering at the workplace again
this is nonsense the reason this is
nonsense number one vaccinated people
are passing covet as well not at the
same rates as vaccinated people as
unvaccinated people but they are passing
it two
what is what is protecting you is not
the mask what is protecting you is the
vases everybody has had the opportunity
to get vaccinated everybody
determine the vaccination status that's
what employers must do determine the
vaccination status of each employee
okay so forget about
any sort of hipaa rules it is now my job
as an employer to determine whether you
are vast or not
obtain acceptable proof of vaccination
from vaccinated employees maintain
records of each employee's vaccination
status and maintain a roster of each
employee's vaccination status so we need
all your information and we need it now
and by the way if osha decides a month
from now that everybody needs a booster
i'll just push that too
support vaccination by providing
employees reasonable time including up
to four hours of paid time to receive
each primary vaccination dose and
reasonable time and paid sick leave to
recover from any side effects
experienced following each primary
vaccination dose
uh so i noticed that they don't do this
with the flu vaccine only with coveted
apparently
ensure that each employee who is not
fully vaccinated is tested for coven 19
at least weekly
or within seven days before returning to
work require employees to promptly
provide notice when they receive a
positive covenant test immediately
removed from the workplace any employee
regardless of vaccination status
who receives a positive covenant 19 test
ensure that every employee who is not
fully vaccinated wears a face covering
when indoors or occupying a vehicle with
another person for work purposes
so if you are unvaccinated we are now
going and you're testing we're going to
and we know so you're testing we know
you don't have it right because we're
testing you theoretically that's the
idea of the testing we're going to force
you to wear a mask
we'll force you to wear a mask knowing
that you're not carrying covet
presumably as some sort of stigma for
the rest of the company so we can all
so that we can all mask shame you or
some such stupidity
hey this is supposed to take effect
pretty much immediately employers must
comply with most provisions by 30 days
after the date of publication in the
federal register employers must comply
with the testing requirement by 60 days
after the date of publication in the
federal register so within a month we
have to be testing everybody once a week
and we have to gather your vaccination
status and by 60 days we have to force
you to vaccinate basically or fire you
and again they are looking at getting
rid of the alternative of testing period
again every single person who wants a
vax can get a vac freedom dictates that
once you have gotten the vax you leave
everybody else alone and that if you're
unbacked you take responsibility for
that
but the notion that the federal
government can activate every employer
in america as the health police
against you forcing you to get
vaccinated forcing you to mask up
shaming you if you don't do these things
or firing you if you refuse to do them
is insane
to do this on the basis of the law from
1970 under an emergency temporary
standard is completely anti the
constitution of the united states
for those who suggest by the way
that the supreme court will approve this
this is because they are ignorant of law
case states are allowed to do things
like bax mandates
states are they have been since the
founding
the federal government was never given
this sort of authority there is no case
that gives the federal government this
sort of authority and particularly does
not give the federal government this
sort of authority under osha for god's
sake this isn't a lo this isn't even a
law passed by the congress of the united
states and the senate and then signed
into law by the president it is a broad
regulation being interpreted by a
workplace enforcement administrative
agency in order to cram down these rules
on right now 100 million americans but
get ready it will be everyone
and this is only the start we got to
fight this now and the reason we got to
fight this now is because i promise you
they're going to go further than this if
they believe that they can get away with
this they'll go further they'll do it
for employee employers who are under 100
employees so everywhere no one will be
able to work unless you get vacced
hey again i am pro-vaccination this has
nothing to do with whether the vaccines
are good or not it has to do whether
with whether freedom is good or not any
time when every single human
has the capacity in the united states if
you're above the age of five to get
vaccinated
and thus protect yourself and then leave
everyone the hell alone
and it's not gonna stop even there
because i promise you now that the fda
and the cdc have cleared the vaccines
for five to 11 year olds you think this
administration isn't going to push
for mandatory vaccination of
five-year-olds in public schools
you think they're not going to push for
that
i have serious doubts
okay this is an authoritarian
administration
this is tyranny it is tyranny and we
will challenge it in the courts we'll
we'll do whatever we must in order to
prevent the implementation of this
authoritarian nonsense
and again it's expensive we need your
help to do it so please
i've made this sort of appeal before but
frankly i think this is the most
important appeal we've ever made at this
company we need your help right now
please go to dailywire.com subscribe use
code do not comply for 25 off
it is just insane for me by the way the
way that they are justifying all of this
is by saying that unvaccinated workers
face grave danger grave danger really my
20 year old vaccine unvaccinated workers
are facing grave danger are they truly
by the way if they were facing grave
danger don't you think that they would
go get vaccinated
and if they don't believe they're facing
grave danger but they have the ability
to get vaccinated isn't that their
problem isn't that their freedom isn't
that a liberty decision for them
they're saying an ets is necessary
because workers are becoming seriously
ill and dying as a result of
occupational exposures to covet 19 when
a simple measure vaccination can largely
prevent those deaths and illnesses so
what you know better than they do
therefore you get to force them
it's just it's vile it's vile
but what can you expect from a biden
administration that has become
increasingly more authoritarian day by
day
and the the authoritarianism here
is the feature not the bug
it is the goal the goal is the control
the goal is not kerbin covet at this
point cobit has been curbed in terms of
its reproductive number
okay this is not about preserving the
health of workers all of whom have the
choice as to whether they want to get
vaccinated or not this is simply about
control
and maintaining the illusion that if joe
biden a senile old bag of stupid hits a
button he will magically fix all of your
problems by forcing you to do what he
wants
stand up right now or you will not be
able to stand up later unite or die make
sure you go over to dailywire.com
subscribe please um really help us out
25 off when you use that promo code do
not comply alrighty now on to the
regularly scheduled show
after taking a shellacking across the
country joe biden and the democrats call
for more spending and say they haven't
done anything wrong at all it's the
children who are wrong i'm ben shapiro
this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
thousands of my listeners have already
secured their internet join them at
expressivevpn.com
ben will get to all the news in just one
moment first black friday is coming up
but you don't need to wait until black
friday to start saving money right now
like in the here and now look at that
bill right the bill that comes every
month one from your cell phone company
you're spending too much on it so stop
it go to pure talk usa and do what the
rest of my listeners are already doing
pure talk gives you killer 5g coverage
on one of the largest 5g networks in the
country and still saves the average
family over 800 a year i made the switch
the coverage is great their us-based
customer service actually cares about
you and pure talks prices are pretty
much wholesale unlimited talk texts six
gigs of data for just 30 bucks a month
keep your number keep your phone or this
month get black friday prices on new
phones like the iphone 12 for just 479
they've got a 30-day risk-free guarantee
so you literally have nothing to lose go
to puretalk.com shop for the plan and
phone right for you then enter promo
code shapiro and you will save 50 off
your first month and save on a new phone
that's puretalk.com promo code shapiro
puretalk is simply smarter wireless some
restrictions apply see site forward
details save yourself a bunch of money
on your cell phone provider coverage
today by switching over to puretalk
promo code shapiro to save 50
off your very first month and save on
your new phone alrighty so
democrats are now responding to the
shellacking that they took across the
country it was not just in virginia in
new jersey for example phil murphy
barely pulled out a gubernatorial race
he was supposed to win by eight to ten
points and members of the new jersey
congressional delegation are looking
cross-eyed at the results they're just
confused by them they're not sure what
to do with them according to mediaite
one of the uh one of the congress people
from jersey said quote effing disaster
down ballot way too close at the top not
enough excitement at the top of the new
jersey ticket biden coveted et cetera no
accomplishments should have passed
infrastructure a month ago now as we'll
see this is going to become a recurring
democratic theme is if only we had done
more of that thing that we promised to
do and that people hated us for then
things would have gone just swimmingly
according to the washington post the
democrats are reeling and they see a
threat to the house and senate control
as republicans crack their 2020
coalition is the washington post again
democrats reeling from the party showing
on tuesday night were sharply critical
of its direction and agenda already the
subject of months of infighting on
capitol hill concluding it threatens to
devastate their efforts to hold on to
the house and senate next year much as
it dragged down this year's candidates
now remember
in virginia right there were districts
that shifted 10 15 points in new jersey
there were districts that shifted 16 but
new jersey basically went dead even
after joe biden won the state by 16
points last time around well if you look
at all the congressional districts that
are within like 10 or 15 points for
democrats you're talking upwards of 70
congressional districts for democrats
that theoretically could be in
competition even if you go conservative
on that and you say everything that's
within six or seven points you're still
talking about 40 to 50 seats for
democrats that are in serious trouble in
the house you're looking at a swing that
looks a lot like the 2010 swing for the
republicans in that particular election
year the democrats lost upward of 60
seats in the house if that were to
happen republicans would emerge with a
vast majority considering the house is
pretty evenly split right now and when
you look at the senate map democrats
actually had a pretty good year on their
hands in the senate at least in an
off-year election right they had a
senate map that was very much tilted in
their favor not a lot of
lean democrat seats that were up a lot
of lean republican seats that were up
and that was a problem for the
republicans well now with the ground
shifting under their feet they have to
be looking at the map and they have to
be quite fearful
according to the washington post in
virginia a state that has become
reliably blue in recent years republican
glenn young defeated democrat terry
mcauliffe according to an ap projection
in new jersey democratic governor phil
murphy was struggling for his second
term the circumstances in the two
governor's races all but confirmed the
collapse of the coalition that propelled
democrats to power during the donald
trump administration and joe biden to
the presidency in 2020. in the elections
wake there are fresh doubts in the party
about biden's ability to push his
domestic agenda across the finish line
and to repel the new attacks republicans
have opened on culture fronts especially
over schools again remember the way that
this works is if democrats do incredibly
radical stuff that's not an attack on
the status quo if republicans notice
then it's republicans who have started a
culture war that's the way the media
portray all of this a new round of
upheaval according to the washington
post over the party's priorities and
strategies appeared imminent
an estimated 3.3 million people turned
out to vote in virginia easily outpacing
the last two gubernatorial elections so
again the lie that republicans need
people to stay home in order to win it
is just that it is a lie in the eyes of
democrats that reflected alarmingly high
enthusiasm and conservative strongholds
and a disturbing shift in the kinds of
suburban areas that powered their gains
in 2018 and 2020.
the big republican turnout and the
suburbs moved back to where they were
pre-trump said jared leopold the former
democratic governors association
spokesman i think the education piece
was a big part of it young kin had a
message about education that was framed
in a positive way for parents so what
exactly is happening here what's
actually happening here is that the
united states is a 50 50 country and the
united states has been a 50 50 country
for a very long time it is not a 60 40
country as democrats would have it nor
is it a country where a durable
democratic majority is emerging
demographically so this was the argument
that democrats continued to make
basically every single day after 2012.
in 2012 barack obama broke all of the
election models he broke the election
models because he was supposed to lose
he was not a good president he was not
particularly popular he had lost some
millions of votes from his victory in
2008. he won a big victory in 2008 he
lost about 3 million votes between 2008
and 2012 and he still won reelection
and political scientists like roy
tashera over at the atlantic were
arguing that this is because
because barack obama had created a new
durable democratic coalition right this
was the pitch the pitch was that barack
obama's new democratic coalition was
going to fundamentally shift how
politics was done in the united states
writing for the center for american
progress to share a guy named john
halpen they wrote obama's strong
progressive majority built on a
multiracial multi-ethnic cross-class
coalition in support of an activist is
real and growing and it reflects the
face and beliefs of the united states in
the early part of the 21st century
the center for american progress called
the strategy quote the culmination of a
decades-long project to build an
electorally viable and ideologically
coherent progressive coalition in
national politics in other words
identity politics cobbled together
enough minorities and college-educated
white liberals to win election after
election you don't have to pay attention
to the suburbs if the suburbs come along
with you great if they don't oh well you
don't have to pay attention to the rural
areas
and then trump came along and he
narrowly eats out a victory and
democrats were able to blame that on
basically the russians and facebook and
claim that he cheated but they kept that
utopian dream alive this durable
democratic coalition
and then in 2020 biden won and he
recapitulated the obama coalition but it
turns out he didn't create the recreate
the obama coalition because that
coalition is particularly durable he
recreated it because donald trump was on
the ballot and trump had largely
alienated suburban women
that was the story of the 2020 election
if trump had performed in 2016 among
suburban women the way that he did in in
2020 he would have lost and vice versa
if he had performed in 2020 the way he
did in 2016 he would have won
with suburban women in 2020. okay so it
was not really about biden recreating
the coalition but democrats have decided
that that that utopian vision of the
undefeatable coalition is real and so
they keep doubling down on this stuff
over and over and over and reality just
keeps proving them wrong it turns out
that barack obama was an electoral
outlier he hadn't created a new durable
coalition he was an electoral outlier
because he's a very talented politician
and because he in his own identity was
very attractive to the american people
who wanted to move beyond race obama
then blew that opportunity for the
united states broadly speaking but that
was the pitch
okay if obama was the outlier then
nobody should be particularly shocked at
the results in virginia
or in new jersey the united states is
not a hard-left country it is not a
country with an emerging progressive
majority that wants to become like
denmark that's not what the united
states is we're a pretty moderate
country we have some right leaning views
particularly culturally speaking on
economics we tend to be somewhere in the
middle
if this is not a hard right country nor
is it a hard-left country and the left
keeps misreading the tea leaves now the
right would be mistaken to think that
this means everlasting victory for the
right but so long as the left keeps
cruising toward the left they're opening
up the middle for people like glen
yonkin they're opening up the middle for
republicans and all republicans have to
do is run down the middle and not be
crazy again we now this is how low the
bar is in american politics right now
whichever party is not crazy wins end of
story whoever is perceived by the
american public as less crazy is going
to win
and democrats right now have embraced a
bunch of crazy crap and republicans are
basically just sitting there
republicans are now running the biden
campaign from 2020 they are sitting in
the basement doing nothing
and just pointing their finger like
donald sutherland at the end of invasion
of the body snatchers
and americans like that's true
okay they're pretty crazy you don't want
to vote for those guys i mean it is the
way you can tell this by the way is
because
literal
anonymous people are winning office
right now there was a guy who just won
named edward door
over in over in new jersey he's a truck
driver he spent 150 on his campaign 150
bucks
right like a nice dinner for you and
your wife
150 bucks he spent on his entire
campaign and he defeated the sitting
president of the state senate in new
jersey by a couple thousand votes was
that because he was such an unbelievably
attractive candidate
no all he had to do was just stand there
and not be dead but also not be super
alive right
we are now in a political moment
where both parties seem to be
increasingly kind of crazy but the
democratic party is going way more crazy
right now than the republican party is
and everyone can tell and so the entire
map is now tilting to the right it's
tilting red we'll get to more on this in
just one second first
you know there are certain medical
problems that people tend to ignore
because it's uncomfortable to talk about
them or you just hope they're going to
go away erectile dysfunction is one of
those medical problems
if you're suffering with that just go
get it solved go to getroman.com ben
right now you can speak to a u.s
licensed health care professional about
erectile dysfunction and get 15 off your
very first month of treatment e.d is a
lot more common than most people think
in fact 52 of men between the ages of 40
and 70 will experience some form of ed
so don't be embarrassed about going to
get help especially if you can do it
quickly and discreetly roman ready is
confidence personified it's the
self-assurance that comes from knowing
that your body is going to work the way
that it needs to work roman's system is
completely confidential totally discreet
no big logos or labels on the packages
with roman you get a free online
evaluation and ongoing care for ed all
from the comfort and privacy of your
home a us licensed healthcare
professional will work with you to find
the best treatment plan if medication is
appropriate it trips you free with two
day shipping the whole process is
straightforward convenient and discreet
getting started is simple go to
getroman.com complete that online visit
take care of your et without leaving
your home go to getroman.com ben today
if you're prescribed 15 bucks off your
very first month of ed treatment make
sure you're ready to have the confidence
and control you need roman ready get
roman.com
ben today alrighty so what does this
mean practically in terms of the map
well
larry sabato who is again
a left-leaning guy who runs the center
for politics at the university of
virginia
he has something called the crystal ball
the crystal ball is is ratings for
particular senate races and right now
he has just moved a bunch of races away
from the democrats so arizona georgia
and nevada were lean d
yeah i always thought by the way that
that was a bit of an overstatement they
are now considered toss-ups by larry
sabato colorado which was a safe
democratic seat is now being shifted to
a likely democratic seat
okay so if you look at the map right now
that means that lean republican seats
include wisconsin which remains a alien
republican seat
and ohio which remains a likely
republican seat unclear who's going to
emerge from that ohio primary whether
it's jd vance or whether it's josh
mandel it'll be interesting to see
because both of them are very trumpy
in the toss-ups according to larry
sabato and the center for politics over
at the university of virginia
pennsylvania georgia arizona nevada
republicans only need to pick up two of
those in order for them to win control
of the senate
nevada looks pretty good for them nevada
is a is an ugly scene right now for the
democrats georgia i think republicans
just win back i think republicans win
back georgia i think it was a fluke that
they lost last time i think it was
largely driven by the fact that donald
trump decided in the final days of the
campaign that he was going to tell
republicans not to vote because of
charges of voter fraud or some such
other silliness the reason i call that
silliness is because whatever you think
of voter fraud not voting is a really
really dumb and stupid solution to that
considering you handed two seats to the
democrats in georgia which is in fact a
red state
okay arizona
it is not christian cinema who's up in
arizona it's mark kelly who's up in
arizona but that state seems to be
trending red again because of the nature
of the the political moment pennsylvania
is a harder state for republicans but a
bunch of pennsylvania appellate court
judges were just elected as republicans
so if there is low turnout in some of
the big cities and democrats do not
duplicate what they did in 2020 in
pennsylvania that could go republican
too so if all shifted to the republicans
you'd be looking at 53 seats for the
republicans in the senate remember all
they need to do is pick up two
they just need to hold in wisconsin and
they need to pick up two more seats
that's it and if they do that they win
the senate so this is now i would say a
likely republican senate map and
democrats are looking at that and they
realize that they are likely to lose
both houses of congress in the next
election cycle
okay it's a disaster for them and so
once again they're presented with some
choices
the choices for the democrats are
you can follow the moderates
you can follow the progressives or you
can follow the crazies now i know that
everybody in politics right now is
separating the the democrats into two
categories rather than three right
they're saying they're the moderates and
they're the progressives and among the
moderates they're counting people like
nancy pelosi and chuck schumer and joe
biden this is incorrect
right now the democratic party is
divided in three ways it's divided
between the crazies that would be on the
spending side carmilla jaipal from
washington on the on the overall side
that would be the squad
the moderates this would be in the house
people like abigail spanberger from
virginia
and in the senate it would be mansion in
cinema
and then you have the progressives the
progressives are actually biden and
pelosi and schumer
the democrats right now are heavily
loaded toward the progressive side they
could stop this right they could do what
bill clinton did after he got blown out
in 1994 he lowered capital gains taxes
he signed on to welfare reform he
started working with the republicans on
the other side of the aisle to come up
with some sort of moderate policy
do you think the democrats are really
going to do that or are the democrats
going to keep doubling down on stupid
it's fascinating to see how this breaks
out down media and across the democratic
side of the aisle because this is a real
open argument in the media and on the
democratic side of the aisle i think
it's kind of hilarious that every time
democrats lose an election they have
this brief moment this just brief moment
particularly the media they have a brief
moment where they're like
what if we talked to people what if we
got out of this little bubble that we
live in here on twitter and we actually
went and talked to people who don't
think like us and we tried to comprehend
what they were saying jim acosta had
this brief moment of clarity yesterday
on cnn it was quite amusing
if you look at what happened in those
red counties those bright red counties
from the shenandoah valley all the way
down to southwestern virginia that is
trump country uh and democrats have not
been able to make inroads in that part
of virginia and those kinds of rural
areas around the united states for a
very long time now and i suspect that
democrats may need to do a little less
lecturing and more listening when it
comes to those rural voters to help them
get back
into the good graces of those kinds of
americans
now i always laugh when i hear this sort
of stuff from the media because they
spent four years doing precisely the
opposite right after trump won
there was this brief moment in time
where democrats like maybe we should
read hillbilly elegy maybe we should
actually send selena zito out to talk to
these these trump voters as though she
was like jeff corwin going into the wild
or something they'd wear like australian
hats and they who are these trump voters
what are they doing how do they think
and then after five minutes they're like
no they're all racist we're not gonna
pay any attention to them anymore
probably it was facebook probably it was
the russians they have this brief moment
of clarity and in that brief moment of
clarity lies the possibility for
democratic hope
they're probably not going to take it i
mean there are other commentators who
are providing sort of this moment of
clarity as well for example there's a
one former obama adviser stephanie
cutter and she says you know we're
really scared of is that the republic
republicans are going to become the
party of parents right we tend to break
americans down by demographic group by
racial group by age group but there is
one group of people who actually are
united by interest that pretty much
nobody has taken advantage of yet and
that of course are parents right once
you have kids your interests change
there's a reason that married women with
kids vote very differently than single
women here's stephanie cutter
recognizing that reality
the one thing that we need to make sure
that uh republicans in 2022 don't become
is the party of parents uh because we
need to be the party
and and we are we're the ones that care
about school funding we're the ones that
care about making sure that parents can
send their kids to school uh because
they have jobs to go to you know all of
this we need to own that agenda we
cannot let it go and it's not just about
critical race theory it's a it's coming
out of covet it's parental frustration
it's parents being involved in their
kids schooling we need to pay attention
to all of it
okay she's right about this democrats
have no capacity to shift they have no
capacity to shift on this they're hocked
the american federation of teachers
which fought hard against kids going
back to school they believe that the
american federation of teachers should
be able to determine solely how your
kids are taught
it's very hard to make the case that
you're the party of parents when you're
also the party of abortion that's a very
difficult argument to make just
philosophically speaking so democrats
have a real problem on their hands with
regard to this stuff the new york times
is recognizing that as well we'll get
some more of this in just one second
first if you own a business you know
there aren't enough hours in a day to
waste time playing phone tag a list of
customers you need to reach it doesn't
get any shorter especially when business
is good and here's the thing
if you are a customer and you've ever
gotten a call from a random business do
you ever pick up the phone you always
let it go to voicemail right but if
somebody texts you from a business you
now have the information and you can
text them back like i
just as a customer i use texting with
businesses a lot more frequently than i
ever pick up the phone from a business
this is why local businesses everywhere
are turning to podium podium makes every
interaction as easy as sending a text so
everything that makes your business
great can get done faster podium isn't
just a better way to communicate it's a
better way to do everything gathering
reviews collecting payments even
marketing to your customers podium makes
it all as easy as pressing send you
won't just free up more time you'll grow
your business and get more done because
again more people respond to the text
join more than 100 000 businesses that
already use podium to streamline their
customer interactions get started for
free at podium.com shapiro or sign up
for a paid podium account get a free
credit card reader restrictions apply
that's podium.com shapiro again
podium.com shapiro go check them out
right now so
stephanie cutter is right and
republicans are realizing that if they
if they go after the parental vote
they're going to do much better which
prompts this hysterically funny headline
from the new york times
quote republicans pence on schools as a
wedge issue to unite the party oh so
much counting it's not the democrats
have perverted the schools and
republicans are responding to it it's
republicans pelts pounds pounds
it's like simba as a cub in the lion
king
pounce
so much pouncing
according to the new york times after an
unexpectedly strong showing on tuesday
night republicans are heading into the
2022 midterms with what they believe
will be a highly effective political
strategy capitalizing on the
frustrations of suburban parents still
reeling from the devastating fallout of
pandemic era schooling seizing on
education as a newly potent wedge issue
republicans have moved to galvanize
crucial groups of voters around what the
party calls parental rights issues in
public schools a hodgepodge of
conservative causes ranging from
eradicating mass mandates to demanding
changes to the way children are taught
about racism yet it is the free-floating
sense of rage from parents many of whom
felt abandoned by the government during
the worst months of the pandemic
that arose from the off-year elections
as one of the most powerful drivers for
republican candidates across the country
democrats lost significant ground in
crucial suburban and ex-urban areas the
kinds of communities that are sought out
for their well-funded public schools
that helped give the party control of
congress in the white house in virginia
where republicans made schools their
central pitch education rocketed to the
top of voter concerns in the final weeks
of the race narrowly edging out the
economy and a lot of credit there to
luke rosiak again our investigative
reporter here at daleyware you want to
help that investigative reporting like
luke's make sure to subscribe at
dailywire.com subscribe with promo code
real news for 25 off according to the
new york times the message worked on two
frequencies pushing a mantra of greater
parental control glenn yonkin the
republican candidate for governor in
virginia stoked the resentment and fear
of some white voters who are alarmed by
efforts to teach a more critical history
of racism in america gotta love how the
new york times like these stupid parents
duped by glenn younkin into being white
supremacists
the attack critical race theory a
graduate school framework that has
become a loose shorthand for contentious
debate on how to address race
no no
and he released an ad that was a
throwback to the days of banning books
so they're just doing propaganda work on
behalf of the democrats like keep doing
this seriously democrats new york times
please keep saying that parents are
concerned about their kids being taught
racial essentialism in public schools
being taught that if you are white
you're inherently privileged and if
you're black or inherently victimized
please keep telling parents that their
kids being taught that stuff is good and
they need to sit down and shut up and
the republicans who notice are pouncing
please democrats in the media keep
saying that public schools should be
cramming down masks on children who are
generally safe from covet again the
total number of kids who have died from
covet who are healthy prior to covet is
10 to 20 across the entire united states
across the entire pandemic according to
marty mccary of johns hopkins university
please keep telling parents they can't
send their kids to school until they
vaccinate their kids let's see how well
this works out for you that's not
republicans pouncing again that is
democrats going crazy and republicans
noting it that's all that republicans
are doing
if you want to see some pretty
devastating results for democrats forget
about the gubernatorial race in virginia
take a look at how the school board
elections went the other night across
the country they went very poorly for
the democrats
as the new york times notes however
young kin and other republicans tapped
into broader dissatisfaction among
moderate voters about teachers unions
unresponsive school boards quarantine
policies and the instruction parents saw
firsthand during months of remote
learning in his some speeches young can
promise to never again close virginia
schools
terry mcauliffe and his party eagerly
condemned the ugliest attacks but they
seemed unprepared to counter the wider
outpouring of anger over schools
this is
again of course they can't counter it
because they're in favor of the
indoctrination
that's the whole thing they're in favor
of the indoctrination they like the
indoctrination they like the top down
control that's the point this is
embedded deep in the marrow of the
democratic party at this point the
public schools as indoctrination centers
for left-wing policy
so yes this is a winning issue for
republicans now democrats could turn
away from it
are they going to democrats could also
turn away from their inflationary
monetary policies they could turn away
from unpopular spending policies they
could turn away from all this stuff
because remember it wasn't just
education it was also kind of economic
policy it was joe biden being unpopular
it was a lot of issues here democrats
are in trouble across the board that
would generally necessitate a very sharp
turn are they going to make that turn
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about the fact that
you know for me
i sort of go through these bouts where
i'm exercising a lot and then i'm not
exercising as much because i'm traveling
a little bit more or because there's too
much going on in life you put on a
little bit of weight i'll tell you what
has been super helpful for me i'm
talking about echelon echelon brings the
gym home and i can't always make it to
the gym when you're trying to reach your
fitness goals it can really help to have
a world-class instructor choreographing
classes music from your favorite artist
a community of hundreds of thousands of
people who can give you that extra push
one of the things i like about echelon i
have a little bit of a competitive
streak when it comes to exercise and so
while you are biking you can see where
you're ranking versus everyone else
echelon gives you that echelon is the
affordable way to get the workout
equipment the workout community and an
instructor's motivation right in the
comfort of your own home echelon's
fitness app provides you thousands of
live and on man classes with excellent
music and with echelon you can work out
anytime day or night crush your fitness
goals just pick your class climb the
leaderboard cheer each other on give it
your all echelons certified fitness
instructors are supportive engaging and
fun and they know how to get you moving
i know because they get me moving
they've got a full range of affordable
workout equipment they've got stationary
bikes that's what i have they've got
smart rollers they've got fitness
screens they've got the auto folding
treadmill
all are connected to provide that
echelon experience and if you get a
membership it covers a family of five
right now for a limited time podcast
listeners get up to eight hundred
dollars off msrp to get this exclusive
podcast discount text ben to 81 81 81
again text ben to 81 81 81 get up to 800
bucks off msrp text spend to eight one
eight one eight one go do that right now
and get yourself in shape the echelon
way by texting ben to 81 81 81 get 800
bucks off alrighty so are the democrats
going to actually start
moving away
from their radicalism
no
i mean the answer the quick answer is no
like christopher walken on snl
they've got a fever and the only
prescription is more cowbell
that is the that's all they've got so
they have a few strategies here strategy
number one we're gonna pretend that this
didn't happen it didn't happen you know
what happened in virginia was natural it
was normal when there's a massive
blowout in virginia where a former dnc
head and former virginia governor gets
his ass kicked that is not worth it's
not worthy of discussion here was joe
biden yesterday saying well you know
this sort of thing happens pretty much
every uh pretty much every election
virginia switches to the the party of
the of the
opposition
here we go here's joe biden
i was talking to terry to congratulate
him today he got 600 000 more votes than
any democrat ever has gotten
we brought out every democrat about
there was more votes that ever has been
cast for a democratic incumbent
i'm not incumbent a democrat running for
governor and no governor
in virginia has ever won when he's of
the same or he or she's the same party
as a sitting president
okay well i mean that's that's sort of
saying a lot considering the fact that
it's been a long time since republicans
have won statewide in virginia like bob
mcdonnell was the last republican
governor of virginia before this so
um i have a feeling that it actually
does matter a little bit but this is
going to be the democratic talking point
is that we we're not doing anything
wrong it's not us it's the children
right so you have this opinion piece
from harry bacon in the washington post
today titled an abnormal republican
party was treated normally by voters in
new jersey and virginia
right he says that really this is not a
big deal it's just that the president's
party generally struggles in off your
elections because there's a turnout gap
that favors the party that's not in
control
and also some voters swing away from the
president's party because they don't
like performance and because they want a
balance of power in government
and really the big issue here is that
voters are stupid so they don't realize
that the republican party is so evil
that they shouldn't have reacted as they
normally do so this is just a this is
the normal course of affairs no listen
it is true that off your elections the
out of power party does better
it is not true that you expect to see
swings like you saw in virginia that is
not a true thing you do not expect to
see the house of delegates completely
reverse itself you don't expect eight
point races in new jersey to almost turn
into dead heat or the republican winning
you do not expect the virginia
governor's race to turn into a fairly
large blowout in favor of the republican
in a state that the democrats just won
by 10.
right there are certain things that are
outside the margin of error you might
expect that in a state where somebody
where joe biden won by four and suddenly
the governor goes red right that you
might expect but where joe biden won by
you generally don't expect that that's
kind of rarity so the first strategy by
democrats here to deal with the fact
that the american public have turned
largely against their agenda is to
pretend that that's not a big deal and
and play it down
and the second thing that they are doing
is they're saying well the real thing
that's happened here is that they just
don't understand us right they don't
understand us this is the the move that
the democrats routinely make when they
lose when al gore lost to george w bush
it was well he was just too smart for
the crowd when john kerry lost to george
w bush's well he was just too
sophisticated john kerry too
sophisticated uh-huh super convincing
right it's always some excuse or another
so joe biden was asked about this now
here's the thing about joe biden
one of the big reasons that terry
mcauliffe got his ass kicked is because
joe biden is a terrible president
everybody knows it
right everybody knows that joe biden is
a bad president he is down in the low
40s there was no excuse for him being
down in the low 40s see here's the thing
about trump trump was never above 50 in
the approval ratings
the day he was elected
his approval rating was like 47
that's about as high as it ever went for
trump he never got above 50 in any
serious way joe biden was up in the mid
50s and now joby's in the low 40s and by
some polls he's down in the 30s he is a
very bad ineffective and terrible
president
he is bad and that he has pursued bad
policies he's ineffective in that he has
not been able to pursue even anything
remotely like a good policy
and he's unpopular because he is
verging on senility so that there are a
lot of bad things
about the biden administration so biden
was asked okay why exactly did you lose
and joe biden says because americans are
confused about what we do here
right the the idea here from democrats
is going to be as we will see
that the reason democrats lost in
virginia is because they weren't
radical enough
again more cowbell here's joe biden
setting the predicate for that argument
i just think people
are at a point and it's understandable
where there's a whole lot of confusion
everything from are you going to ever
get coveted under control
to
are my kids going to be in school are
they going to be able to stay in school
to whether or not
i'm going to get a tax break that allows
me to be able to
pay for the needs of my kids and my
family
and they're all things that were that
we're gonna that i'm running on but
we'll run on and i think we'll do fine
i think we'll do fine um yeah good luck
with that joe he also said it's not his
fault he says not me i didn't do it stop
blaming me joe biden the top of the
ticket
alrighty joe
do you take some responsibility and do
you think that terry mcauliffe would
have won if your agenda had passed
before election day
well uh
i think we should have should have
passed before election day
but i'm not sure that i would be able to
have changed the
number of very conservative folks who
turned out in
the red districts who were trump voters
but maybe maybe
no i i i know we did but i we also i was
running against donald trump
boom dirty little secret that he just
let out of the bag right there no one
likes his agenda even joe biden realizes
it ain't about his agenda it's about he
was running against trump in 2020 and
trump had really high negatives among
suburban moms
that's the reason why he won but he
can't it's gonna go down really it'll go
down in history joe biden will
as one of the worst political decisions
of all time to take the tack he has
taken it's really unbelievable he was
elected on the basis of being a moderate
he literally defeated bernie sanders in
the primaries because he was not bernie
sanders and then he turned around as
president and he embraced bernie sanders
he he was elected to not be divisive
racially and then he turned around and
he embraced the entire ibrahim equity
agenda
it's bewildering like on a political
level it's bewildering now on an eagle
level you understand why he's doing it
because again this is a daughtering old
man who wants to go down in history
alongside lbj and fdr and he's likely a
one-term president and he knows it but
on a pure political level he took
whatever popularity he had based on the
entire image that he was running as
moderate and he flushed it down the
toilet he basically ran as joe manchin
and then he governed
as like
the the senate as like ed markey right
it's crazy
that is it that is a poli and he's
leading his entire party down this path
right because again he and the rest of
the democratic party are they're infused
with the notion that that 2012 obama
coalition is replicable
and that all they're just one big
spending bill away from that becoming a
permanent coalition they are not one big
permanent coalition in fact their
policies are not popular with a broad
swath of the american people but joe
biden has to keep doubling down because
he has no other choice he has boxed
himself in here so here he was yesterday
saying the thing here the real problem
is that people want us to get things
done no maybe joe maybe it's that you
did too much already
maybe it's that the things you want to
get done are unpopular maybe republicans
are being elected to stop your agenda
not to facilitate your like that's such
a weird argument it's such a weird
argument i'm promising to do x i've been
unable to get x done because i don't
have enough democrats in favor of what
i'm doing
the public then votes in a bunch of not
democrats and your response is oh well
you know probably they loved my agenda
what how does that make any sense
they're literally voting for people to
stop your agenda
that's literally what they are doing
and and then joe biden's like yeah but
we need more
here he is people want them to get
things done apparently
[Music]
and no governor in virginia has ever won
when he's of the same or he or she's the
same party as a sitting president
what i do know is
i do know that people want us to get
things done
they want us to get things done
and that's why i'm continuing to push
very hard
for the democratic party to
move along and pass
my infrastructure bill and my bill back
better bill
and they want us to do more that's what
they want
more
more always
and uh if this daughter in old fool
isn't enough for you i've got another
daughter on old fool for you that's
nancy pelosi the house speaker so she
was asked about this yesterday and she
basically think
the people spoke and we heard them
and we will ignore them
does he change the agenda for uh the
house no
no
does it change the agenda for the house
and this is this is the tactic they're
going to pursue now more tim kaine
senator from virginia his state just
turned red
okay and here's tim kaine yesterday
saying ah the big problem here is that
the congressional democrats didn't pass
the infrastructure bill that's the big
problem here if we pass the
infrastructure build and terry
mccullough would have won uh-huh sure
sure him
congressional dems hurt terry mcauliffe
i mean i'm going to be blunt it's
humbling to say it but
if we had been able to deliver
infrastructure and reconciliation in
mid-october
he could have sold
universal pre-k
affordable child care
infrastructure creating jobs democrats
control both houses and they have to act
like they have to be disciplined have to
get results
and the um you know our
our
inability to come together and get a
result hurt him
okay mark warner saying the same thing
again senator from virginia saying no no
what this is what we need we need more
more of this it's astonishing it's
astonishing none of them have the
capacity except for joe manchin as we'll
see it's actually maybe we should wait
on this for a moment here is here's mark
warner pushing the same the same gospel
here
you guys got
the white house the senate
the house
when he get more things done
i mean only in washington
could people think
that it is a smart strategy
to take a once in a generation
investment infrastructure and prevent
your president from signing that bill
into law and that's somehow a good
strategy
because that's warner actually ripping
the congressional progressives that's
hilarious about this is that you got
warner and kane saying if the
congressional progressives had gone
along with infrastructure we would have
won in virginia
that's not true pramila jayapal is
saying well if you guys had just gone
along with us i'm buildback better than
we would've won
how about none of that would have made a
damn bit of difference because americans
aren't calling for any of this crap
you're already spending too much money
no one is desperate for the
infrastructure plan no one is desperate
for a bill back better no one's
desperate for any of it that's why
republicans just won but here's camilla
jayapal saying yeah you know it really
isn't about the infrastructure bill it
was really about build back better
again the the conversation here in
reality is not a two-way conversation
between the moderates and the
progressives the conversation right now
is between the moderates the
progressives and the radicals and the
progressives and radicals are going at
each other but in reality the only
people they should be listening to are
the moderates they're not going to
here's pramila jayapal
there is no way that you can blame a 12
point swing on one bill the reality is
that voters do want us to deliver i
think young can
appeal to parents and education i think
we have the formula to appeal to parents
even more by passing a bill that
provides child care that provides pre-k
um that provides jobs
so again this is the agenda okay so
they're not pushing this thing forward
we'll get to how they're pushing this
forward in a second because it's crazy
it's crazy
this is a party with a death wish
apparently
we'll get some more of this in one
second first
you may have noticed that gas prices are
out of control right now you may want to
save some money at the pump i mean who
doesn't want to save money at the pump
this is why you need to get upside my
listeners are making up to 25 cents for
every gallon of gas every time they fill
up just download the free get upside app
in the app store or google play right
now use promo code shapiro get a bonus
25 cents per gallon on your first fill
up that's up to 50 cents cash back don't
pay full price at the pump anymore get
cash back using get upside just download
the app for free use promo code shapiro
to get up to 50 cents per gallon cash
back on your first tank some people who
drive a lot are making as much as two to
three hundred bucks a month in cash back
there is no catch the cash back gets
added directly to your account you can
cash out anytime to your bank account
paypal or an e-gift card for amazon and
other brands just download the free get
upside app use promo code shapiro to get
up to 50 cents per gallon cash back on
your very first tank of gas that is
promo code shapiro when you use that
free get upside app if you can save much
money on that gallon gas why exactly
wouldn't you when you can do that for
free go to get upside right now use that
promo code shapiro get up to 50 cents
per gallon cash back on your very first
tank of gas alrighty
get some more on this in just one moment
first americans are the targets of the
corporate propaganda machine known as
the mainstream media it's time to start
waking up to the constant deception and
start exposing the skeletons they keep
locked firmly in their closet the daily
wire is doing everything we can to bring
you the truth every single day our
investigative journalism movement is
really going strong and making a big
difference the talents of our
journalists unparalleled luke rosiak
broke that loud and county sexual
assault story and it moved the needle in
virginia for sure we watched it as his
excellent work along with the work of
journalists like chris ruffo affected
real change in the virginia election
which essentially turned into a
bloodbath for the democrats but
investigative journalism as we've
mentioned many times is very expensive
that is why there are not a lot of
right-wing investigative journalists
this is why we need your support for as
little as four bucks a month you can
help us keep exposing the truth and
reclaim the narrative every new member
who joins our ranks strengthens our
ability to build up our investigative
unit if you want to join us in that
fight go to dailywire.com subscribe use
code real news to get your fix of real
news today you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so democrats in the aftermath of what's
happened are ramping up the spending
ramping it up according to the wall
street journal house democrats are
adding back in provisions to the build
back better plan
that are big spending provisions nancy
pelosi wants to vote on it like today or
tomorrow now the senate is not going to
vote on it manchin and cinema don't
support this bill she wants to add in a
bunch of stuff and then ram it through
so that she won't be blamed for what
happened in virginia the other day
they're crazy this is crazy talk
according to the wall street journal
house democrats released an updated
version of the party's social spending
and climate package adding back in a
paid leave program that had previously
fallen out of the bill including a
measure sharply raising the ten thousand
dollar cap on the state and local tax
deduction the house bill which top
democrats want to bring up for a vote in
the chamber is the latest proposal in
the months long negotiation among
democrats over biden's agenda it's set
to face changes in the senate where joe
manchin has objected to the inclusion of
a paid leave benefit the bill includes a
variety of measures proposing a
universal pre-k program for three and
four-year-olds subsidies for child care
and health care costs tax credits for
reducing carbon emissions among other
measures the white house the house tax
leaves many of those items largely
unchanged from the white house 1.85
trillion dollar framework released last
week
i mean i'm sorry but this is crazy
and and the fact that nancy pelosi is
pursuing it just shows she's throwing up
her hands and she's basically like
effort i'm just gonna i'm gonna throw
out whatever i feel like throwing out
i'm gonna get somebody's gonna vote for
something around here and i'm just gonna
throw out a big bill and make democrats
vote for that bill now here's the
problem what if all the moderates in the
house are like no
what if abigail spanberger in virginia
says
not into it
they've got
they are having a serious issue right
here again there are enough of the
mansion cinema style moderates in the
house and in the senate to say maybe we
should hold up on the big spending bill
and now nancy pelosi has reversed the
order before it was we'll pass
bipartisan infrastructure because
there's more support for that and then
we'll pass bill back better now nancy
pelosi wants to pass bill back better
before bipartisan infrastructure
that's not going to work none of this is
going to work but the idea is you just
throw more crap at the wall and hope
that something sticks because this is
desperation point for the democrats and
they cannot pull out of the tailspin
they are they're already over the cliff
hey this isn't thelma and louise headed
for the cliff they are already over the
cliff they just haven't hit the ground
yet this is wiley coyote he's over the
cliff it's that moment in the cartoon
where he realizes and he looks down and
gravity has not yet applied and you see
his eyes get real wide and then
that is what this is the democrats just
haven't hit the ground yet
according to the washington post a new
sense of political urgency swept over
rest of democrats from the white house
to capitol hill on wednesday as they
race to resolve the final issues
stalling president biden's roughly 3
trillion economic agenda in the
aftermath of a stinging election defeat
in virginia with a loss in that state's
gubernatorial race along with a slim win
in new jersey party lawmakers found
themselves anxious exasperated newly
ready to try to advance two spending
initiatives that have been bogged down
in congress for months now here is the
problem again there are enough moderates
in the house in the senate true
moderates to say no
not super into it for example joe
manchin yesterday he came out he's like
you know you guys are saying we need to
speed this up i'm saying i think we need
to slow this down here is joe manchin
the actual president of the united
states
i i just think that the messenger is
really sent if we're going to do
something let's take time and do it
right let's make sure that people know
what's in it
and i've said that before sometimes the
the the it's not intentionally the
game's being played this way the system
is very convoluted people need to know
that what we're getting for what you're
going to expect how much you're going to
pay for it and go on and on and on but
you know we're talking about revamping
the whole entire
tax code
that's mammoth totally
okay he's saying americans are concerned
about inflation he is not wrong
he is not wrong by the way americans are
so concerned about inflation that the
fed just announced yesterday that they
are tapering their buys they're they're
buying they're dialing back their their
bond purchases they're starting to taper
now because they're afraid of inflation
in fact the fed chair jerome hell he
said yesterday that temporary inflation
had become not so temporary because it's
not permanent which is always very
reassuring
transitory is um
is a word that uh people have has
have had different
understandings of for some it carries a
sense of
of uh
and that's that's you know there's a
real time component measured in months
or let's say really for us what
transitory has meant is that if
something is transitory you will not
leave a behind it permanently or or very
persistently higher inflation
okay so yes it turns out that the vast
majority of people think of transitory
as it's going to end
that is what transitory means i love
that we're now in clintonia and
clintonia and what does is mean what is
the definition of is the definition of
transitory it's like well if it lasts
for like two years i guess it's still
transitory okay so they're starting to
taper the buy americans are worried
about this they're paying more for
everything and joe biden wants to blow
more money into the economy which is
leading people like abigail spanberger
from virginia again she's a virginia
blue dog democrat she says mr biden must
not forget that for many voters his
mandate was quite limited to remove
former president donald trump from their
television screens and to make american
life ordinary again nobody elected him
to be fdr they elected him to be normal
and stop the chaos
okay points to abigail spanberger right
there
and yet the democrats won't stop can't
stop won't stop
right nancy pelosi wants to hold the
boat according to punch bull news they
do a good job summarizing everything
going on in dc
they want to hold a vote on both build
back better and the 1 trillion
bipartisan infrastructure bill today or
tomorrow in the house
you read that correctly they say a vote
sometime in the next few days on
legislation calling for nearly three
trillion dollars in federal spending
that's been delayed for weeks
they said when you when you look at the
dynamics it doesn't make any sense
when looking at house democratic
strategy you begin to end with pelosi
she wants to vote on on buildback better
first and then infrastructure pelosi's
had an interesting journey during this
buildback better process first she said
the house would only vote on the
bipartisan infrastructure bill after
the senate passed the reconciliation
package then she caved on that then she
tried to pass the infrastructure bill
twice and that failed and here we are
with the house on the brink of
considering a massive 1.5 trillion plus
reconciliation package that won't pass
the senate
so pelosi has been forced to give a lot
of ground process wise as well as
policy-wise
and now she's saying you know what i i'm
just going to throw it in schumer's lap
i don't know what to do here i'm just
going to go with it pelosi's biggest
hurdle according to punchbowl is the
moderates five democratic moderates have
publicly declared they want a budgetary
score before they vote for bill back
better that's not going to happen here's
a top aide to a moderate democrat at
this point so many members are
bewildered by leadership's latest
strategy it appears we've given up on
pre-conferencing and there's no way to
know the full cost and repercussions of
all the newest additions and changes i
think frustration is growing by the lack
of a strategy to get this into law and
that it appears we are doubling down on
the wrong lessons from tuesday also
where is the president
he's sleeping it off is where the
president is
meanwhile the progressives are like yeah
you know build back better let's let's
just cram a bunch of crap in there and
then we'll send it over to mansion and
see what we can do on this it's amazing
so the democrats are going to try and
ram this thing through
they do not have the they do not have
the capacity to do this
kathleen rice of new york again one of
the democratic moderates in a in a
purple district she said i don't
understand some of my more progressive
colleagues saying tuesday night shows us
we need to get both of these bills done
and shove even more progressive stuff in
what we're talking about is not
resonating with voters
correct
so
the democrats are going to tear each
other apart all because they cannot let
go of this notion that their ideas are
right it's the american people who are
wrong all right we'll be back here later
today with an additional hour of content
in the meantime go check out the michael
knowles show today he discusses his take
on colin kaepernick comparing the nfl
combine to the slave trade you can hear
more details about that story over on
michael's show that's available right
now i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
is mixed by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
the establishment gop learns nothing
from glenn young's victory democrats
turn on white women and left-wing
commentator van jones admits that his
fellow liberals are super duper annoying
check it out on the michael knoll show
[Music]